think the fights are better it's uh I
just the audience just drives me crazy
me too yeah and I think it's just it's
just fun to watch but like even when you
saw that I don't know if you saw the
fight before the Brendan Allen and
you're on versus daucus he's from
Louisiana yeah he was really really all
in Allen baby and but that dog is kids
who that wasn't just the UFC debut
fought hard yeah yes a lot or even yeah
he fought hard man I think both those
guys will have you know continued to
have good success it was you know it's
interesting cuz even Dustin said after
the fight he goes he likes it better
without the audience there oh he did say
that yeah which I thought was
interesting cuz you would think like
from our from comedy it's like a you
want people to be in there but I guess
is probably like you're saying like it's
almost like podcasting it's like it's
more comfortable sometimes when it's
just you or when it's just a small group
because you can kind of Zone in on a
little bit more on what you're doing
you're not doing it for someone you're
doing it more for yourself you know yeah
and that's exactly it like when I look
at those fighters there's no audience I
feel like they're fighting because they
love it right there's no okay they're
not performing for anybody they it's in
their bones they're out there to fight
and it's really inspiring to see those
guys beat the [ __ ] out of each other for
25 minutes with no one around
yeah but they would be bombed it would
be bummed though if they fought no
audience but then somebody told them
afterwards we forgot to turn the cameras
on and they're like bleeding right only
seven people watched it that was wrong
back right yeah and they're like you
have to do it again when a year yeah
it's like man I'm not doing that again
for a year I wonder my eyebrows in my
pocket right now what that's crazy which
boys um because either one that's
employee yeah was boy yay his I was he
fought like because I've never talked to
because we've had Bisping on our podcast
and but we've never talked to I've never
talked to a fighter directly after a
match right or fight was he coherent
yeah it was funny
and he showed up about an hour and how
he had to go to the hospital he said and
um so I just went up there I met up with
his wife and some of his friends who
were sitting there watching the fight
about five people six people maybe and
then had to go to the hospital one thing
that he said that was really funny was
he said at the hospital he's in one like
stall or whatever they're called in Dan
hooker who's also anime seem like an
amazing dude is in the other stall and
this is a curtain between him and Dustin
said he goes and I told him he goes hey
man I just heard we got the fight of the
Night bonus yeah and uh and hooker goes
oh that's great man still feels just the
same I would have laughed at that me too
man that's one of the beautiful things I
love about humor is that just sometimes
some jokes can only be it can only
happen in one space in one time yeah and
there's no it can never happen again man
yeah that's one of my favorite things
about about humor
Gus is really funny man I think a lot of
people get to see a lot of his
personality but he's really really funny
but it was cool man he came back and he
just dressed like like he just [ __ ]
he always do that there were suit up oh
yeah yeah like I'm a professional yeah
and I guess they are man it was fun we
got to sit and watch the fight again so
we sat and watched the fight on his
computer and just um yeah it was just it
was just interesting then to be able to
watch him I kind of go through the fight
and yeah I don't know he just loves
fight and he just loves it you can tell
well what I found interesting in the
fight was between the fourth and fifth
round his corner man or his coach goes
you having fun out there having a blast
right that's not what I would say yeah
oh yeah I can't feel nothing I mean or
said you know there's blood in my skull
I can feel blood in my skull you know
something like that we're you know what
you say I don't think say I would having
a blast out there there's a something
does it look like a blast I think you
have to do that in case they hear you
across the cage and to just tell
yourself what are you gonna owe and I
think that's where they're able to do
that kind of that kind of sport because
I'm like you man I'm just fast and
by the fact that those guys can do that
cuz I don't have that in me
you know I just have that thing that's
more just fear you know yeah be able to
just go past those moments of like of
fear and see what's on the other side of
them in anything it's pretty wild but I
can understand that that's why I like it
I could understand going through a scary
situation and coming out the other side
right yeah and that kind of like and
especially if you win but even someone
like Dan hooker he knows like if I went
in there and I have asked it I knew I
didn't train that good right in the
third round like I want to do this
anymore but if you're like a Dan hooker
you could tell he put everything on the
[ __ ] line yeah and so he's sitting
there next to Poirier and also fight of
the night and all that you know when you
lay in bed even though you lost you know
that it's for the history books
mm-hm yeah I mean no one's gonna watch
that and go everyone said on Twitter and
stuff wow that Dan hookers a beast that
was a close fight what a warrior yeah
right
and he he can take that with them in his
life and that probably motivates him for
the next fight I think it's an addiction
in that that's that's I I don't care
about rankings like when I look at a
fighter I always care about and Dustin
Poirier is a perfect example of that
when has he ever had a boring fight yeah
ever yeah like we always watch his
fights I don't care how he's ranked
where he falls in that number where he
falls there I will always watch him
forever yeah yeah there's something yeah
it's something it's something it's
something that's just amazing to see
some of these guys do how they manage it
and how they then afterwards sometimes
go back to like they're respectable you
know they still respect each other and
stuff I think there is also a level like
you're saying Bobby of like earning a
respect win or lose yeah feels like a
win-win like I thought that was going
win for them and for us I feel bad for
they're like the ones that that aren't
in UFC the amateur fighter oh yeah they
have a holiday in yeah yeah right within
the next day they're like delivering
Domino's Pizza
yeah yeah with both their arms or from
balancing it on their shoulder up to the
door I feel bad for those guys like even
in like the Premier League in England
flip the soccer right the fourth tier
guys yeah right because there's what
seven hundred teams yeah in England but
they you know have their matches they
still have to go to practice but then
they also have to go to their accounting
job yeah in the lower tiers in the lower
tier okay yeah so I just feel better you
know I just feel bad for that part
that's what yeah that's how you know
they they just love to do it yeah and
that's meritocracy - you got to have
that you got to have I think people that
earn their way into the to the big space
you know yeah how do you feel about
comics and I missed I've been struggling
with this for many many years and I
think I've changed my point of view on
it do we sound like smart people do you
notice that all in the past have to be
silly Billy
no I know I just feel like we've just we
should bring it back down we should take
it down the notchback too low bro yeah
we need somebody yeah well I'll talk
about my dig later